[Music]
so we usually meet up tomorrow for our
PS Plus update but this month
PlayStation are trying something
different
announcing games over multiple days
instead of all at once but that's fine
that's okay because right now today you
can download this PS plus game as soon
as the store has updated in your country
as of May 26 get your hands on Call of
Duty World War 2 this may be a strange
move as war zone is doing pretty damn
good right now but that's where World
War 2 offers something different
firstly a dramatic single-player
campaign reliving key moments in the
Second World War landing at the beaches
of Normandy and battling across Europe
and experiencing firsthand the
unforgiving nature of war on top of that
we have the good old zombie mode a
cooperative horror fest in which we take
on the zombie Nazi hordes in this
iteration they try to build in a complex
story about the zombies with a chilling
and dark mission behind enemy lines
uncovering the mystery powers behind the
axis of evil and finally of course the
multiplayer portion is here and
hopefully this update will breathe new
life into the online servers again Call
of Duty World War 2 introduces divisions
to multiplayer they're kind of like
reimagined create a class systems
choosing between five iconic divisions
during World War two so if you're
looking for another game to play this
month here you go
download it right away so it looks like
I'll be back again tomorrow with more PS
+ games I'll see you then thanks for
sticking around see you soon
[Music]